this is the first time you've directed a
happening of monumental proportions yeah
it is how did you learn to direct well
you do you can go to film school which I
think there's like some really good
programs in Los Angeles or you can or
you can do like a million movies so I
chose the latter you've been getting
directed hundreds of times and that's
how you learned how to do it that is how
I thought I would learn how to do it but
it's hard to direct a movie
I wouldn't know never tried it no one
wants me to know I don't want me to know
I would because I would spend my whole
time acting like an old-timey director I
you know what I mean i'd get a beret and
i'd be like yeah I have the big
megaphone I'd be like oh quiet on the
side you'd be like John Ford have no
interest in making the movie I would
just act like an ass the whole time
you've got a great cast you got Jen
garner you got common you've got I mean
Bradley Whitford and this is a great you
know I do I guess I'm him I'm John Cho
unders home Katie Holmes
Rob Riggle Allison Janney I mean can you
even believe all these people say that's
amazing that's great so what do you call
me your Judy Greer so did you call
people up and say that emails no one
answers their phone anymore so yeah I
emailed people and I asked for a lot of
favors and like actually Kumail Nanjiani
is in my movie and he's so funny and
he's worked for one day on my film and
he and I had met on an independent
called addicted to Fresno a few years
before and he did a day on that and he
was the funniest person I'd ever worked
with after you of course and that was so
close you saved that one in just a nick
of time
he was so funny and I was so thankful
that he gave his time and drove out to
Simi Valley where he had to shoot that
one day and and I was like oh my gosh
thank you so much Camille I don't even
know how to thank you and he's like oh
you know don't worry about it I said
it's so hard to make indie films and he
said I know I'm about to make one with
my wife my wife and I wrote a screenplay
and we're gonna shoot it and I was like
that is adorable that you two would like
do a little project together you know if
you need any help on it at all like
anything at all please just let me know
like
craft service come work for a day
anything he's like okay we're we're good
but thank you and then of course it was
the big thick which got to the Oscars
was also really special time with
Bradley Whitford on set where I I walked
in the similar trap and he was like oh
I'm doing this like weird little horror
movie out in South Carolina and I was
like yeah that's a real you know
everyone has to do one more movie you
know like you got to do it yeah get your
side just get it out of the way horror
movie patch let me know if you guys need
anything yeah and then that was get out
you know we found out from the story as
long as you're condescending about a
movie it'll be a smash yet the secret
formula
you